In the previous lesson,
we saw that most hospitals and around half of
all providers now use an electronic medical record or EMR system.
It is easy to forget just how remarkable this is since as recently as
2008 only 4% of providers had what we now call a basic EMR system.
Perhaps even more surprisingly, in 2009,
only 1.5% of non-federal hospitals had one.
These statistics come from a pair of
important papers published in The New England Journal of Medicine,
generally regarded as the leading journal in the field.
I recommend you read them.
Federal hospitals who are excluded from the study,
largely because the Veterans Administration, the V.A.,
the nation's largest integrated health care system was
a pioneer and all of their hospitals had EMR as well before the study was done.
The V.A. has veterans information systems and technology architecture or Vista for short,
dates back to the 1980's and consists of nearly 180 applications for the VA's clinical,
financial, administrative, and infrastructure needs.
All integrated into a single common database.
Here is an example of Vista's capabilities,
showing that images can be retrieved by any physician in the system,
no matter where in that huge system those images are stored.
This capability is still not widely available elsewhere in U.S. healthcare.
So, in less than a decade,
we went from 4% of providers having a basic human system to around half.
How did this transformation toward
a more interconnected system occur in less than a decade?
Many people including me long argued that
only federal intervention would make EMR adoption happen.
A core reason for this is once again, economics.
Without federal intervention, hospitals and providers would have to invest,
to go through a difficult, time consuming,
and often frustrating transition from paper to electronic records.
Moreover, under the pay for procedure reimbursement model,
to the extent the EMR led to a reduction in unnecessary or duplicative care,
it might negatively affect their revenue.
Moreover, EMR adoption is an example of network benefits.
The more providers that have them,
the more valuable they become because of data sharing.
In such a situation it is always hard to find enough early adopters,
willing to innovate in the hope of some future gain.